bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic
température et chaleur prenons un objet
par exemple une pomme vu à notre échelle
cette pomme semble parfaitement immobile
cependant si l'on s'intéresse à
l'échelle microscopique la pomme est en
réalité constitué d'une multitude de
molécules qui sont elles-mêmes fait
d'atomes il se trouve que ces molécules
qui composent la pomme sont constamment
en mouvement
en effet elle se déplace très rapidement
et ne cesse d'entrer en collision les
unes avec les autres
ainsi même si depuis l'extérieur la
pomme semble parfaitement immobile à
l'intérieur toutes les molécules qui la
composent sont en réalité constamment
agitée c'est ce degré d'agitation
microscopique au niveau des molécules
d'un objet que l'on appelle sa
température de cette façon si les
molécules de la pomme était plus agitée
on dirait que la température de la peau
mais plus élevés et à linverse si les
molécules étaient moins agitée on dirait
que la température de la pomme est plus
faible
dans l'univers il existe toute une gamme
de températures différentes
en effet il existe des objets très chaud
dont la température est très élevé mais
également des objets très froid dont la
température est très basse
toutefois il est impossible de trouver
dans l'univers un objet qu'ils soient
plus froid que - 273,15 degrés celsius
en effet à cette températures
extrêmement basses les molécules de
l'objet sont si peu agitée qu'elles sont
en réalité complètement immobile il est
alors impossible de refroidir davantage
l'objet car il a déjà perdu tout son
agitation
on appelle cette température minimale le
zéro absolu
dans la pratique il est impossible
d'atteindre le zéro absolu
cependant il est aujourd'hui possible en
laboratoire de s'en approcher à quelques
dixième de milliardième de degrés
celsius
les objets de notre univers ont donc
tous d'une certaine température
cependant au cours du temps la
température d'un objet peut se modifier
et ce à travers l' échange d'un certain
type d'énergie qu'on appelle la chaleur
par exemple un objet à peut donner de la
chaleur un objet b d'une part l'objet à
va se refroidir
car il perd de la chaleur et d'autre
part l'objet b va se réchauffer car il
récupère cette chaleur qui a été
transmise il existe dans l'univers trois
types de processus qui permettent ainsi
aux objets d'échangé de la chaleur tout
d'abord si l'on met en contact un objet
chaud avec un objet peu froid les
molécules de l'objet show qui sont très
agités vont s'entrechoquer avec les
molécules de l'objet froid et ainsi
elles vont leur céder une partie de leur
agitation
de cette façon lorsqu'on touche un objet
froid notre corps va communiquer une
partie de sa chaleur à cet objet est
ainsi ayant perdu un peu de chaleur on
ressentira dans notre main une sensation
de froid
ensuite la chaleur peut également se
déplacer en suivant le mouvement d'un
liquide ou d'un gaz par exemple si l'on
chauffe un verre d'eau par le bas l'eau
qui se trouve en bas sera plus chaude
que l'eau qui se trouve en haut comme le
froide est plus lourde que l'eau chaude
elle va redescendre au fond du verre
alors que l'eau chaude va remonter la
chaleur qui se trouvait alors en bas
s'est donc déplacé en suivant le
mouvement de l'eau enfin les objets
convertissent tous une partie de leur
chaleur en énergie lumineuse qui se
traduit par un rayonnement plus l'objet
est chaud plus le rayonnement va être
énergétique par exemple notre corps
humain qui n'est pas très chaud émet de
la lumière infrarouge qui n'est pas
visible à l'oeil nu mais qui peut par
exemple être détecté par des caméras
thermiques le soleil quant à lui à une
température extrêmement élevée
il est donc constamment en train
d'émettre des rayonnements infrarouges
lumineux et ultraviolet qui vont se
propager dans le vide
certains de ces rayons vont notamment
parvenir jusqu'à la terre en absorbant
une partie de ces rayonnements la
surface de la terre valeur gagne et de
la chaleur et par conséquent se
réchauffer
ce phénomène qui permet de convertir
chaleur en rayonnement est le seul type
de processus qui permettent un échange
thermique à travers le vide
c'est grâce à ce phénomène que le soleil
est en mesure de réchauffer la terre
depuis des dizaines de millions de
kilomètres ceci permet notamment la
présence d'eau liquide à la surface
terrestre ou encore le développement de
la vie complexe telle qu'on la connaît